bonjour france belvaux
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on le sait une
année déjà très compliquée entre locaux
vides et la hausse des prix des matières
premières ce réveillon de fin d'année
c'est un enjeu très important pour la
profession
oui c'est un enjeu important même s'il
va se dérouler dans des conditions
particulières puisque je vous rappelle
qu elle qu il est maintenant interdite
danser en france dans les bars les cafés
des restants d'envoyer un 31 décembre en
étant assis en lançant trois cotillons à
minuit il ya déjà énormément
d'annulations dans les restaurants et
les hôtels pour ce 31 décembre ouais ça
a été une mesure prise par décret
préfectoral
vous vous attendez à quoi de ce conseil
de défense qu'est ce que vous redoutez 1
un couvre-feu
- couvre-feu on a quelques informations
de la préfecture de police de paris on
peut penser qu'il y aura un couvre-feu
mais située à deux heures du matin un
bon ce qui serait acceptable à partir du
moment où toute façon les discothèques
sont fermées et où il est interdit de
danser voilà le pire pour être et là on
est rigoureusement contre le contrôle
des pièces d'identité avec le pass
vaccinale when the past vaccinale
devraient le projet devrait être adopté
à l'issue de ce conseil de défense en
conseil des ministres tout à l'heure
ne devraient pas être imposées avant
avant janvier ça va que ça va ça va
faire de nouvelles contraintes pour vous
ce pass vaccinale
non nous je vous rappelle que nous on
contrôle déjà le pass annie terre depuis
le 1er septembre à la fois pour nos
clients et à la fois pour nos équipes
puisqu'il ya un taux de vaccination dans
nos équipes qui est très très important
donc non kong le contrôle et le pass
vaccinale on le fera ce pas un problème
là où on est rigoureusement contre ces
deux noirs contrôler les pièces
d'identité parce qu'on n'est pas
policier on n'est pas gendarme à chacun
son métier on ne demande pas aux
policiers de venir faire cuire le le
boeuf bourguignon ou l'appli la pièce de
viande donc chacun chacun son métier
nous on n'est pas là pour contrôler les
pièces d'identité ouais c'est cette idée
de contrôle d'identité c'est parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de faux pas sanitaires
comment résoudre le problème je crois
que votre syndicat aussi une proposition
c'est par exemple de mettre une photo
sur le passé en der
alors ça peut être effectivement une
photo mais je crois qu'il faut surtout
s'attaquer aux fiches galles on parle de
180000 faux-pas sanitaire ce qui est
scandaleux il faut s'attaquer aux
filiales ne faut pas sanitaire qu'on
peut trouver sur le net je pense que
l'état doit mettre une procédure très
forte et et puis s'attaquer à ces
filières qui sont scandaleuses et au
lieu de vous demander de faire des
contrôles d'identité il faudrait aussi
trouver des solutions pour le rendre
inviolable
oui tout à fait voilà c'était à chacun
son métier nous on est là pour servir
les clients pour faire la cuisine pas
pour contrôler les pièces d'identité je
pense que l'état en a bien conscience
on y dort on parle toujours les
restaurateurs toujours les restaurants
les bars les cafés qui sont depuis cette
crise depuis mars 2020 la variable
d'ajustement de ce christ kobe donc là
en nous on est déjà
au maximum
on vous entend pas très bien franck
delvaux on va réessayer d'accord sai on
vous entend bien on relève l'année une
année on l'a dit déjà déjà très
compliqué il y à 7 cette mesure qui est
envisagé de d'écourter les délais
d'isolement pour les cas contactez
j'imagine que dans votre profession il
ya aussi deux de l'absentéisme
oui on est une profession déjà tendue en
terme de d'employés en termes d' équipe
effectivement mais à la fois comme les
artisans vous aimiez bien un boulanger
un électricien comme nous les
restaurateurs et il faut jeu il ya déjà
certains restaurants qui sont obligés de
fermer faute de personnel parce qu'il ya
trop de chalco vide ou deux cas contacts
donc effectivement ça doit être une
bonne mesure pour un grand nombre de
professions manuelles alors s'il avait
ces restrictions il y a encore pour pour
votre secteur que demandez-vous
gouvernement d aide d'accompagnement
évidemment
pas nous on demande déjà vous savez on
rompt parle d'environ une baisse de
chiffre d'affaires par rapport à 2009 de
l'ordre de plus de 20 % pour la
restauration voire plus pour
l'hôtellerie sur le mois de décembre on
demande de l'ars la remise de
réactualiser le fonds de solidarité en
fonction des baisses de chiffre
d'affaires
ok sont innotech pied le prêt garanti
par l'état
90% des entreprises de notre domaine
l'on reporté d'un an donc là on va
devoir le rembourser au mois de mars
avril 2022 avec toutes les difficultés
pas possible donc on me demande de
décaler ce prêt garanti par l'état au
moins d'un an et de le rembourser sur le
10 ans un bien rassure évidemment ce
conseil de défense en direct sur notre
antenne merci beaucoup franck delvaux
d'avoir répondu à notre merci en direct
sur arte france